il y a encore sans doute devant nous
deux ou trois jours de fortes chaleurs
malheureusement c'est déjà le deuxième
épisode de caniculaire que l'on vit cet
été on a vu des phénomènes que les
foresties n'ont jamais vu avant
puisqu'on a des pannes de 40 ans les
troncs par rapport par rapport à la
température qu'on atteint 41 degrés sont
attendus cet après-midi à Vannes jusqu'à
42 dans le reste du Morbihan un record
absolu pour cette région malgré tout
leurs efforts les flammes ont progressé
et englouti 1000 nouveaux hectares au
total sur les deux sinistres en Gironde
à La Teste-de-Buch et à Landiras face à
ces deux incendies hors normes
l'inquiétude se lit sur tous les visages
car depuis hier la situation est
extrêmement préoccupante
on a lancé un cri d'alarme un cri
d'alerte en demandant non pas plus de
moyens mais juste que nos moyens soient
tous disponibles vous savez combien il y
a de Canadair qui marche là
vous savez combien il y en a qui
marchent la France
est le pays européen le mieux équipé
c'est pas vrai on raconte n'importe quoi
ça c'est la propagande il y en a assez
de cette propagande tous les jours nous
sommes déjà payés européen qui dispose
de la plus grosse flotte aérienne pour
lutter face au incendies et nous avons
trois nouveaux avions qui sont commandés
ou en instance de livraison et d'autres
qui viendront dans les dans les années à
venir évidemment
disponibles sur Canada il faudrait qu'on
soit 22 de façon à assurer une
permanence des alliances sur les feux
lors des périodes de risque et lors des
périodes de travail importantes comme on
connaît à l'heure actuelle aussi pour le
projet de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat qui
arrive à l'Assemblée parmi les
principales mesures de soutien les
revalorisations anticipées des pensions
de retraite des prestations sociales un
chèque alimentaire ce sont des
politiques de chèque qui ne vont pas
traiter le problème ce que je propose
comme les LR comme le RN comme beaucoup
de parlementaires le prix des carburants
c'est le prix du carburant ne doit pas
supérieur à 1,50 € non parce qu'elle
coûte 50 milliards d'euros et qu'elle
n'est pas de nature à répondre à
l'objectif qui est le nôtre c'est de
protéger l'économie de notre pays et les
économies des Français on veut des
mesures qui durent dans le temps qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée et non pas du
ripolinage des morceaux de scotch du
rafistolage c'est ce que nous propose
aussi le gouvernement tout le week-end
les téléphones ont chauffé tout azimut
qu'on a consulté à gauche qu'on a
consulté à droite la première ministre
si émise l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement l'ont fait les rapporteurs
à l'Assemblée aussi pour trouver des
voies d'accord et pour être capable de
dire à des oppositions le plus dur et
devant nous
le plus dur nous y sommes le plus dur
nous y sommes pour quelques mois encore
raison pour laquelle nous devons
maintenant accompagner le compatriotes
aucun groupe aucun parti politique aucun
député n'intérêt à dire à la fin de la
semaine que ce texte n'est pas adopté
parce que s'il n'est pas adopté ça veut
dire que le pouvoir des Francs d'achat
des Français ne sera pas protégé elle
représente l'ensemble de ces mesures 20
milliards d'euros d'aide supplémentaire
à nos compatriotes aucun pays européen
n'aura fait autant que la France pour
protéger ses concitoyens un avion de
tourisme étant difficulté en plein vol
vendredi dernier fort heureusement le
pilote a pu actionner le parachute et
l'appareil s'est craché en douceur après
le choc avec le sol on voit le pilote
sortir de la cabine visiblement il va
bien ce texte de loi complètement en
dehors des réalités vécues par les
Français le montrent Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas changé ce gouvernement n'a rien
appris les députés de cette minorité
présidentielle n'ont rien compris y
compris dans votre camp le socialiste
Jérôme par exemple et le député de la
nupesse il dit c'est pas possible on
peut pas mettre sur le même plan le
président de la République est
rassemblement national
vous voyez vous dans mon tweet que je
compare Macron et Pétain va-t-il panneau
la présidente du groupe insoumi elle est
dans l'agressivité permanente elle vous
parle pas elle vous engueule elle écrit
pas elle offense ce tweet est
extrêmement cynique si les
responsabilités posées alors nous
pouvons reproduire des crimes
abominables et c'est ce sur quoi je
lançais l'alerte à ce moment là